foreign
my name is Alex faraj welcome to let's
start at the beginning bits the
character encoding in R I'm a data
scientist and analytics manager at
Accenture Federal Services I spent a lot
of time thinking about R NLP database
and statistical learning my most recent
work is on the hugging phase r package
to bring hugging face models and tools
to R so how would you describe the
letter A to a computer today I'll
discuss how in doing so we'll get into
the shallow end of a deep pool known as
bits to character encoding and we'll
talk a little bit of what that looks
like in R so what do we mean by bits the
character encoding especially in
relationship to NLP well computers don't
speak the same language as we do if we
want to use compute as a process
language you need some way to encode
language so that computers understand
and vice versa both the encoding and the
decoding process needs to be identical
on both ends of the human computer
translation falls apart the agreed-upon
method is called a protocol
so back to the question how would you
describe the letter A to a computer oh
we do so by using numbers of course to
represent letters so instead of a we
could have one B could be two and so on
WE assign a number to represent each
unique character or symbol we want to
communicate computer store numbers in
binary obviously and all signals inside
a computer have two possible values zero
or one each of the zero one pieces of
information are called bits one bit can
represent two value two bits can
represent four three bits represent
eight and so on so how many bits is
needed to represent 256 values using the
logic just discussed it's eight bits
when computers were first developed the
decision was made that a byte was the
next standard unit above a bit a byte is
defined as eight bits in the 1960s
computer developers had one byte to to
work with they developed a protocol to
fit into this one byte called ASCII this
protocol can assign a unique number to
all letters in the English language Plus
numbers symbols and control characters
and everything fits into this one byte
budget and even better seven of the
available eight bits were needed over
time the need to fit more information
grew larger but luckily there was that
extra bit to work with things got
standardized into Latin one which uses a
full 8-bit available in the single byte
so then after that a new standard was
developed utf-8 each character in utf-8
is represented using a prefix U followed
by a four digit hexadecimal number the
difference between binary and
hexadecimal numbers are at a scope for
this brief talk well what's important to
note here though is that utf-8 converts
a code point or a single character in
the Unicode into a set of one to four
bytes and can encode all one million
plus Unicode code points character
strings in R can be encoded in Latin one
utf-8 or as raw bytes these decorations
can be read or changed using the
encoding function the concept of native
encoding is important here natively
encoded strings are strings written in
whatever code page the user is using as
of the 4.2.0 release R uses utf-a as the
native encoding prior to this release
that was not the case because Windows
versions prior to Windows 10 didn't
allow it post Windows 10 this was
allowed and R was updated to take
advantage of this feature this is an
exciting change for us focusing on
nlpnrs and it mitigates a lot of
potential problems for common NLP tasks
it's also helpful to keep this in mind
when using common functions like
read.csv where character encoding can be
set on Linux Linux excuse me and Mac OS
the native encoding has been utf-8 so
this isn't an issue there native
encoding is why we see unknown here as
well for example we see coffee as
unknown even though it's clearly ASCII
compliant ASCII strings will never be
marked with a declared encoding since a
representation is the same in all
supported encodings the sys.getlocal
function will tell you what your native
encoding is the localization information
function is another helpful function and
lastly we have the I convert function
which uses system facilities to convert
a character Vector between encodings so
how does a tidy verse tackle uh encoding
we turn to the Stringer Library which is
built on top of the extreme extensive
excuse me stringy package we can specify
the encoding of a string with the string
convert function and for fun let's
create a little function here that
applies a random encoding via the string
I String encode list function and that's
it thanks for hanging out with me
[Music]